có họ hội đồng ăn điện ngày 25 tháng 15,
tổng thống ngave là đi May 14, đáng nhận được kế hoạch qua bình,
20 tạm điểm, giò Mỹ đi xuất và nghe đánh giá phân kẹn này
có thể đặt nền tảng cho sải phát tại Ukhaina.
Zoon hội dùng gí tế cho đủ thảo lợt.
Đây được call là phía bản cập nhật của đây xuất từng sây dự,
so cu gặp dự ở MPC và tổng thống Mỹ đu đình Trump tại Alaska.
Tự quách xin tình, nhà chẳng cho biết tổng thống đơn Trump đang làm việc chức tiếp
với khách kế và mắt gặp nhằm thuộc đại tính trình chẳng giúp dụt.
Tổng thống đơnơn Trump sự kiến Ukhaina sẽ đưa ra phản hội
chính ngày 25 tháng 15, nhưng đỉnh gỏa khẳng nân xa hàng nếu đối thoại đã tính truyền.
Trong khi đào tổng thống Ukhaina vô lột đi MPC cho biết đã chơi đời
gần một tĩnh lần hồ bị phó tổng thống Mỹ trên event và bộ chứng lột quân